Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I sincerely regret that you should have been obliged to give up your intention of going to Vienna for the funeral ceremonies. I should have liked personally to express to you my sincerest thanks for your sympathy in my keen sorrow, a sympathy which has greatly touched me. By your warm and sympathetic condolence, you have given me renewed proof that I have in you a true and reliable friend, and that even in the darkest hours of trial, I can always count on you. The attack directed
感谢您收听《历史的余味》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我衷心遗憾您不得不放弃前往维也纳参加葬礼的计划。我本想亲自向您表达我最诚挚的谢意，感谢您对我深切悲痛的同情，这份同情深深触动了我。通过您温暖而富有同情的慰问，您再次向我证明了您是我一位真诚可靠的朋友，即使在最黑暗的考验时刻，我也总能依靠您。针对
against my poor nephew is the direct consequence of the agitation carried on by the Russian and Serbian panslavists, whose only aim is the weakening of the Triple Alliance and the destruction of my empire. At the heart of the Sarajevo affair was not just the single bloody deed of an individual, but a well-organized conspiracy, the threads of which reached to Belgrade, which constitutes a constant danger to my family and to my realm. After the latest terrible events in Bosnia. You must surely agree that we cannot live any longer with this Serbian antagonism, and that as long as this furnace of criminal agitation at Belgrade goes unpunished, all European monarchies are in danger. So that, Dominic, was Emperor Franz Joseph, the 436-year-old Austro-Hungarian emperor, writing to the Kaiser Wilhelm II. And he wrote that letter on the 2nd of July 1914.
我可怜侄子的袭击，是俄国和塞尔维亚泛斯拉夫主义者煽动活动的直接后果，他们的唯一目的就是削弱三国同盟并摧毁我的帝国。萨拉热窝事件的核心不仅仅是一个人的血腥行径，而是一个组织严密的阴谋，其线索直达贝尔格莱德，这对我的家族和我的王国构成了持续的威胁。在波斯尼亚发生最近这些可怕的事件之后，您一定同意我们不能再忍受这种塞尔维亚的敌意，只要贝尔格莱德这个犯罪煽动的温床不受到惩罚，所有欧洲君主国都处于危险之中。所以，多米尼克，那是436岁的奥匈帝国皇帝弗朗茨·约瑟夫写给德皇威廉二世的信。他是在1914年7月2日写下那封信的。
But it's delivered to the Kaiser three days later, is it not, by the special envoy of the Austro-Hungarian government, Herr Hoyos. Yes, Tom. Guten Tag, everybody, or should I say, grüß Gott, since we are in Österreich. That was very nice, Franz Josef. Thank you. Yeah, I enjoyed that a lot. Did you like the kind of modulated range of emotion? I did. He starts off calm, and then he gets more and more irate as he gets
但它是三天后才送到德皇手中的，不是吗？由奥匈帝国政府的特使霍约斯伯爵送达。是的，汤姆。大家下午好，或者我应该说，上帝保佑，因为我们在奥地利。那真是太好了，弗朗茨·约瑟夫。谢谢。是的，我很喜欢那个。你喜欢那种调节情绪的范围吗？我喜欢。他开始时很平静，然后随着他变得越来越愤怒，他变得越来越
furious with the thought of these Serbian conspirators. Yeah, the furnace of conspiracy, or whatever he. Yeah, the furnace of conspiracy or whatever he calls it, the furnace of criminal agitation, very stirring stuff. So last time we were really focused on Austria, how there were lots of people in Austria, especially the chief of their general staff, General Franz Konrad von Hützendorf and the foreign minister, Count Berchtold,
对这些塞尔维亚阴谋家的想法感到愤怒。是的，阴谋的温床，或者他称之为的任何东西。是的，阴谋的温床或者他称之为的任何东西，犯罪煽动的温床，非常令人振奋的内容。所以上次我们真正关注的是奥地利，奥地利有很多人，特别是他们的总参谋长弗朗茨·康拉德·冯·赫岑多夫将军和外交大臣贝希托尔德伯爵，
who have long been thinking about what to do about Serbia and been thinking about a preemptive strike. And now, of course, they have their chance. But I think, as we said last time, important to say that assassination of Franz Ferdinand and Sophie is not just a pretext. It is something they take very seriously in and of itself. So Franz Josef, where he says there, you know, the threat to my realm and my family, I mean, he really believes that. Of course. Yeah. I mean, his wife has been murdered by an anarchist. His son took his own life in a weird suicide pact. His nephew has now been shot by a Bosnian terrorist. His brother was killed by Mexican revolutionaries. Yes. Danger everywhere. Yeah. That sense of being embattled and encircled. I mean, a lot of the participants
他们长期以来一直在考虑如何对付塞尔维亚，并一直在考虑先发制人的打击。现在，当然，他们有了机会。但我认为，正如我们上次所说，重要的是要说，弗朗茨·斐迪南和索菲的遇刺不仅仅是一个借口。这本身就是他们非常认真对待的事情。所以弗朗茨·约瑟夫在那里说，你知道，对我王国和家族的威胁，我的意思是，他真的相信这一点。当然。是的。我的意思是，他的妻子被一名无政府主义者谋杀了。他的儿子在一个奇怪的自杀契约中结束了自己的生命。他的侄子现在被一名波斯尼亚恐怖分子枪杀。他的兄弟被墨西哥革命者杀害。是的。到处都是危险。是的。那种被围困和包围的感觉。我的意思是，这个故事中的许多参与者
in this story feel this, but I think it's important to say the Austrians absolutely do feel it. And you get a sense of that, I think, in that wonderful reading that you did, Tom. So we also talked last time about the Kaiser, didn't we? About the person who's going to be reading this letter. But let's concentrate for a second on how the letter gets there. So we are now a week after the assassination. The 5th of July, which is a Sunday, Count Alex Hoyos, who is a sort of younger Austrian diplomat. Oh, I misranked him then. I apologise to you. What did you call him?
都感受到了这一点，但我认为重要的是要说奥地利人绝对感受到了。我想，在你所做的精彩朗读中，你感受到了这一点，汤姆。所以我们上次也谈到了德皇，不是吗？关于那个将要阅读这封信的人。但让我们集中精力谈谈这封信是如何到达那里的。所以我们现在是暗杀事件发生一周后。7月5日，星期日，亚历克斯·霍约斯伯爵，他是一位比较年轻的奥地利外交官。哦，我当时把他排错了。我向你道歉。你叫他什么？
I called him Hare. Yeah, you did call him Hare. Yeah, sorry. Well, I mean, if the Hoyos family are listening, they can take it up with you. Well, I apologise unreservedly. Oh, that's kind of you, Tom. You don't want to know the Dr. Valverde imbroglio, do you, I suppose? No, I don't. So Count Hoyos arrives in, and it's absolutely deserted.
我叫他“野兔”（Hare）。是的，你确实叫他“野兔”。是的，抱歉。好吧，我的意思是，如果霍约斯家族在听，他们可以找你算账。好吧，我毫无保留地道歉。哦，你真好，汤姆。你不想知道瓦尔韦德博士的纠葛，对吧，我想？不，我不想。所以霍约斯伯爵到达了，那里绝对空无一人。
And the reason is, it's the summer. Everybody's on holiday. So the Chancellor of Germany, Theobald Bettmann-Holweg, is away on his country estate. The head of the army, the chief of the general staff, Helmut von Moltke the Younger, he has a problem with his liver, and he is off taking the waters in Carlsbad, which is now in the Czech Republic. Of course he is. Because as we have already discovered,
原因就是，现在是夏天。每个人都在度假。所以德国总理特奥巴尔德·冯·贝特曼-霍尔维格在乡间别墅度假。军队首脑，总参谋长小赫尔穆特·冯·毛奇，他的肝脏有问题，他正在卡尔斯巴德（现在在捷克共和国）疗养。他当然在。因为正如我们已经发现的那样，
key events in 20th century German history all involve spa towns. Yeah. And the Kaiser himself is actually getting ready for his holiday. He will be going probably tomorrow or the next day on his trip to the Norwegian fjords. So he always loves a Baltic cruise. The Kaiser, he loves yachting. Of course, Tom, as we have established. Yeah, a bit of a smorgasbord. Yeah, he loves all that. He likes the bracing Baltic waters.
20世纪德国历史上的关键事件都涉及温泉小镇。是的。而德皇本人实际上正在为他的假期做准备。他可能明天或后天就要去挪威峡湾旅行了。所以他总是喜欢波罗的海游轮。德皇，他喜欢游艇。当然，汤姆，正如我们已经确定的那样。是的，有点像自助餐。是的，他喜欢所有这些。他喜欢清爽的波罗的海水域。
I've been to that neck of the woods and was attacked by a jellyfish. So have I. We'll come to my interaction with the events of the Kaiser's yachting holiday in due course. So that's something for people to look forward to. That is exciting. So first of all, people to look forward to. That is exciting.
我去过那个地方，被水母蜇了。我也去过。我们将在适当的时候谈到我与德皇游艇假期事件的互动。所以这是人们可以期待的事情。这很令人兴奋。所以首先，人们可以期待的事情。这很令人兴奋。
So first of all, Count Hoyos goes to see an old friend of his called Arthur Zimmerman. And if we have American listeners, that name may ring one or two bells, because Arthur Zimmerman later will write a very consequential telegram that brings the United States into the war. But at the time, he's the kind of coming man in the foreign office there. They're all China hands. So they had been in China during the Boxer Rebellion, 1900. So they have a little chat about China and all that kind of thing,
所以首先，霍约斯伯爵去见了他的一个老朋友，名叫亚瑟·齐默尔曼。如果我们有美国听众，这个名字可能会敲响一两声警钟，因为亚瑟·齐默尔曼后来会写一封非常重要的电报，将美国卷入战争。但在当时，他是外交部里那种前途无量的人。他们都是中国通。所以他们在1900年义和团运动期间都在中国。所以他们聊了一些关于中国和所有这类事情，
Hoyos and Zimmerman. And Hoyos is very frank to Zimmerman. And he says, look, I've got these letters. I'm looking forward to handing them over, getting the Kaiser to see them. Personally, he says, I would like to see us hit Serbia really hard and actually just wipe it out. Let's partition Serbia among ourselves, the Austrians, the Bulgarians, and the Albanians." He says, actually, Serbia must be destroyed. It's very kind of Carthago de Lenda-est. He just says, you know, we have to be really hardline about this. But actually, Hoyos is not going to get to see the Kaiser himself. The man who's going to see the Kaiser is the Austrian ambassador.
霍约斯和齐默尔曼。霍约斯对齐默尔曼非常坦率。他说，看，我有这些信。我期待着把它们交出来，让德皇看到它们。他个人说，我希望看到我们狠狠地打击塞尔维亚，实际上就是把它消灭掉。让我们在奥地利人、保加利亚人和阿尔巴尼亚人之间瓜分塞尔维亚。他说，实际上，塞尔维亚必须被摧毁。这非常像“迦太基必须毁灭”。他只是说，你知道，我们必须在这方面采取非常强硬的路线。但实际上，霍约斯本人并不能见到德皇。那个将要见到德皇的人是奥地利大使。
Now, Tom, I was very harsh on you last time by making you read the name. Okay. I was going to say, I won't make you do it this time. Do you want me to do it? Have a crack? You can have a crack. Hungarian is famously with Finnish. Yeah.
现在，汤姆，我上次让你读这个名字时对你非常苛刻。好吧，我本来想说，这次我不会让你这么做了。你想让我来吗？试一试？你可以试一试。匈牙利语和芬兰语一样出名。是的。
And Basque, the most difficult languages for Indo-European speakers to master. And this gives a demonstration why. So the Austrian ambassador is Count Laszlo Szugini Maric de Magyar Szugien et Solzsag. I mean, it's like a jumble of Scrabble pieces. I mean, I'm not much better, to be honest. I did try to look this up.
还有巴斯克语，是印欧语系使用者最难掌握的语言。这展示了原因。所以奥地利大使是拉兹洛·塞切尼·马里奇·德·马扎尔·塞切尼·埃特·索尔扎格伯爵。我的意思是，这就像一堆拼字游戏的碎片。说实话，我也不比你好多少。我确实试着查了一下这个。
He's actually called Count Laszlo Szugini Maric de Magyar Szugien Solzsag. Apologies to Hungarian listeners. Yeah. Anyway, he's Count Szugini. I think Count Szugini how we'd call him. So Count Sir Jenny is the Austro-Hungarian ambassador. He's obviously, as you can tell from that, a Magyar. He is kind of the head boy of the Berlin diplomatic corps, because obviously the Austrians are
他实际上叫拉兹洛·塞切尼·马里奇·德·马扎尔·塞切尼·索尔扎格伯爵。向匈牙利听众道歉。是的。无论如何，他是塞切尼伯爵。我想我们应该叫他塞切尼伯爵。所以塞切尼伯爵是奥匈帝国大使。正如你从那一点可以看出，他显然是一个马扎尔人。他是柏林外交使团的领头羊，因为显然奥地利人
very close to the Germans. Everyone kind of slightly defers to him among the other ambassadors. He is very popular. The Kaiser loves him. The Kaiser's always playing jokes and japes on him. And the Kaiser calls him, you are my gypsy, my little gypsy, and all this kind of stuff because of his Hungarian-ness. So he's given these two documents and he goes to the Kaiser's palace in Potsdam to hand them over. Now, it is a sign, as Thomas Otte points out in his book, July Crisis, of just how unseriously the Germans have prepared for this, that nobody has briefed the Kaiser before the ambassador comes.
与德国人非常亲近。在其他大使中，每个人都有点迁就他。他非常受欢迎。德皇很喜欢他。德皇总是对他开玩笑和恶作剧。德皇称他为“我的吉普赛人，我的小吉普赛人”，以及所有这类事情，因为他的匈牙利血统。所以他拿到了这两份文件，并前往波茨坦的德皇宫殿去递交它们。现在，正如托马斯·奥特在他的书《七月危机》中所指出的那样，德国人对此准备得如此不认真，以至于在大使到来之前没有人向德皇通报情况，这是一个迹象。
You know, if this was the United States right now, he would have a little piece of paper. He'd be Joe Biden and he'd have a piece of paper with bullet points telling him what they want, what we want, where we want to get to. The Kaiser has nothing like this. But also, just to ask you, if Germany was the Germany of, I guess, popular perception, that it's full of shaven-headed Prussians plotting the invasion of Belgium, and they're just looking for an opportunity, that's clearly not the case here. They haven't thought, oh, brilliant, this is a chance for us to invade France. Oh, no, I would say not at all. Now, maybe some people listening to this will say, oh, gosh, Sandbrook and Holland are going very easy on the Germans here. This is very poor form.
你知道，如果现在是美国，他会有一张小纸条。他会是乔·拜登，他会有一张写着要点的纸，告诉他他们想要什么，我们想要什么，我们想达到什么目标。德皇根本没有这样的东西。但也要问你，如果德国是我想象中大众认知里的德国，到处都是剃光头的普鲁士人在策划入侵比利时，而且他们只是在寻找机会，那显然不是这里的情况。他们并没有想，哦，太棒了，这是我们入侵法国的机会。哦，不，我会说一点也不。现在，也许听这个节目的一些人会说，哦，天哪，桑德布鲁克和霍兰在这里对德国人太宽容了。这太糟糕了。
But no historian who's really studied this in detail would make that claim because Wilhelm has spent that morning in that Sarajevo series. We had those lovely scenes of him and Franz Ferdinand bonding over their rhododendrons. Remember that? Yeah. So the Kaiser has actually been doing that this morning. He's gone and he's been admiring the rose bushes in his Potsdam garden. And then he went to a little, they'd put on a special exhibition for him of works by a
但没有真正详细研究过这一点的历史学家会提出这种说法，因为威廉那天早上一直在那个萨拉热窝系列节目中。我们有那些可爱的场景，他和弗朗茨·斐迪南因为他们的杜鹃花而建立了联系。还记得吗？是的。所以德皇那天早上实际上一直在做那个。他去欣赏了波茨坦花园里的玫瑰丛。然后他去了一个小地方，他们为他举办了一个特别展览，展出了一位
kind of historical painter called Professor Scherbel. And the Kaiser has been looking at all these paintings of scenes from German history. Ah, lovely, lovely paintings, nice roses. And then he goes in for this meeting with the Austrian ambassador. And it's not like there's the whole apparatus of the German war machine behind him. There's nobody there. There's just the two of them. So Genie hands over these two documents. Now, one of them is basically just a sort of quite boring strategic overview of Austria's position in the Balkans. And the second one is the one you read out at the beginning. So that was the letter from Franz Josef. And that's the personal appeal.
名叫谢贝尔教授的历史画家的作品。德皇一直在看所有这些德国历史场景的画作。啊，可爱，可爱的画，漂亮的玫瑰。然后他去参加了与奥地利大使的这次会面。这不像他背后有整个德国战争机器的机构。那里没有人。只有他们两个人。塞切尼交出了这两份文件。现在，其中一份基本上只是关于奥地利在巴尔干半岛地位的相当无聊的战略概述。第二份就是你开头读的那一份。所以那是弗朗茨·约瑟夫的信。那是个人呼吁。
It's the personal appeal. It's been very carefully drafted by the Austrian foreign ministry. And it's an appeal to the Kaiser on the principle of our great friendship, your friendship with Franz Ferdinand, and the principle of monarchical solidarity. No European monarchy is safe with these crazy terrorists running around. And Wilhelm looks at all this, and actually at first, he's pretty calm. You know, he doesn't start shouting, let's invade Argentina or something. running around and wilhelm looks at all this and actually at first he's pretty calm you know he doesn't start shouting let's invade argentina or something in his traditional way i shall get out
这是个人呼吁。它是由奥地利外交部非常仔细地起草的。这是对德皇的呼吁，基于我们伟大的友谊、你与弗朗茨·斐迪南的友谊以及君主团结的原则。没有欧洲君主国在这些疯狂的恐怖分子到处乱跑的情况下是安全的。威廉看着这一切，实际上起初，他相当冷静。你知道，他没有开始大喊，让我们入侵阿根廷什么的。到处乱跑，威廉看着这一切，实际上起初，他相当冷静。你知道，他没有开始大喊，让我们入侵阿根廷什么的，用他传统的方式，我应该拿出
the crown of burgundy and give it to the belgians none of this nonsense he actually says listen i completely understand where you're coming from you know you've suffered a terrible provocation and he says that said you know i understand why you want a serious action against Serbia, but there is a risk of a serious European complication to this. Because Serbia is aligned with Russia. With Russia. So we'll kind of have a think about it. I need to talk to my chancellor, Bethman Holweg. So again, the idea that the Kaiser is an absolute monarch, or he's a bully and everybody lives in his shadow, it's not quite right. The Kaiser knows he has to talk to the civilian leaders. But they then go and have lunch, don't they? And then after lunch, he starts to kind of Kaiser a bit. Yeah, he does exactly.
勃艮第的王冠并把它给比利时人，没有这些废话。他实际上说，听着，我完全理解你的立场，你知道，你遭受了可怕的挑衅，他说，话虽如此，你知道，我理解为什么你想要对塞尔维亚采取严肃行动，但这有导致严重欧洲并发症的风险。因为塞尔维亚与俄国结盟。与俄国。所以我们会考虑一下。我需要和我的总理贝特曼-霍尔维格谈谈。所以，德皇是绝对君主，或者他是一个恶霸，每个人都生活在他的阴影下，这种想法并不完全正确。德皇知道他必须与文职领导人交谈。但他们随后去吃午饭了，不是吗？午饭后，他开始有点像德皇了。是的，他确实如此。
So they have this lunch. God knows what they have at the lunch that gets him into this. Something very hot. I think he's just been thinking about it. His friend has been killed, all of this stuff. And he's sort of worked himself up. So when they reconvene after lunch, he says to the ambassador, Sir Ginny, he says, actually, do you know what? I completely understand why you want to have a crack at the Serbs. And I've been thinking about it and you have my absolute full support. I will talk to the Chancellor, Bethman Holbeck, but he's bound to agree with me. And you know what as well? You shouldn't hang about. You know, you should strike quickly. Well, that's an important point, isn't it?
所以他们吃了这顿午饭。天知道他们在午饭吃了什么让他变成这样。一些非常辣的东西。我想他只是在思考这件事。他的朋友被杀了，所有这些事情。他有点让自己激动起来了。所以当他们在午饭后重新开会时，他对大使塞切尼说，他说，实际上，你知道吗？我完全理解为什么你想对塞尔维亚人下手。我一直在考虑这件事，你得到了我绝对的全力支持。我会和总理贝特曼-霍尔维格谈谈，但他一定会同意我的。而且你知道吗？你不应该犹豫。你知道，你应该迅速出击。好吧，这是一个重要的点，不是吗？
He's not wrong with that. It's a really important point. He's not wrong at all. He says, listen, the Russians will make a huge hullabaloo about this. There's no question about that. However, I'm pretty confident the Russians won't do anything stupid. We will stand by you, so that will deter them. The Russians don't want war.
他在这点上没错。这是一个非常重要的点。他一点也没错。他说，听着，俄国人会对此大惊小怪。毫无疑问。然而，我非常有信心俄国人不会做任何愚蠢的事情。我们会支持你，所以这会威慑他们。俄国人不想打仗。
They're not prepared for war. It'll probably be fine. And again again he repeats at the end the current moment is the most advantageous one it would be a massive mistake not to exploit it this is the best chance you'll ever have so never let a crisis go to waste never let a crisis go to waste you know you don't want this shock of the crisis to completely dissipate and I think every historian would say the Kaiser's not wrong there. No. This is the obvious moment. We talked about that in the previous episode.
他们没有为战争做好准备。这可能会没事的。而且他最后又重复了一遍，当前时刻是最有利的时刻，不利用它将是一个巨大的错误，这是你永远拥有的最好机会，所以永远不要浪费一场危机，永远不要浪费一场危机，你知道，你不想让危机的冲击完全消散，我认为每一位历史学家都会说德皇在那里没错。不。这是显而易见的时刻。我们在上一集中谈到了这一点。
Yeah, exactly. The longer you leave it, the less the sense of international outrage fades. Right, exactly. So the question, therefore, is what is the Kaiser thinking? What's going on in the Kaiser's head? Is this because he dreams of world conquest and fighting all his enemies and a world war in which Germany will be victorious? I think there is no evidence of that. I mean, he is specifically saying to the Austrian guy, there won't be a world war. So this is your chance to kind of crack on and do it.
是的，完全正确。你拖得越久，国际愤怒的感觉就越淡。对，完全正确。所以问题在于，德皇在想什么？德皇的脑子里在想什么？这是因为他梦想征服世界，与他所有的敌人作战，以及一场德国将获胜的世界大战吗？我认为没有证据表明这一点。我的意思是，他明确地对奥地利人说，不会有世界大战。所以这是你采取行动的机会。
But also he has flagged up the fact that the risk is of provoking Russia. And this is a bad thing. Yeah, exactly. That it's a bad thing and preferably a thing you'd want to avoid by deterrence. Yeah. Is he being motivated here by his famous hostility and loathing of the british absolutely not the british never mentioned at all really i think what this is his textbook kaiser you know he's had his lunch whenever he has lunch with visiting dignitaries he loses it and just starts ranting this is what he has done and as thomas otte says there is a personal dimension. I mean, it's so easily overlooked. This is his friend who was killed.
但他同时也指出了挑衅俄国的风险。这是一件坏事。是的，完全正确。这是一件坏事，最好是通过威慑来避免的事情。是的。他在这里的动机是他著名的对英国的敌意和厌恶吗？绝对不是，英国根本没有被提及。我认为这是典型的德皇，你知道，他吃了午饭，每当他和来访的政要共进午餐时，他就会失去理智，开始咆哮，这就是他所做的，正如托马斯·奥特所说，有一个个人层面。我的意思是，这太容易被忽视了。这是他被杀的朋友。
And he takes it very seriously. And he thinks they should be punished. Why would you not punish them? So the meeting breaks up. And then the Kaiser goes to the garden. And there, some of his sort of bigwigs are waiting, including the Prussian war minister, who is called Erich von Falkenhayn. And he says to them, guys, the Austrians
他非常认真地对待这件事。他认为他们应该受到惩罚。你为什么不惩罚他们？所以会议结束了。然后德皇去了花园。在那里，他的一些大人物正在等待，包括普鲁士战争部长，名叫埃里希·冯·法尔肯海恩。他对他们说，伙计们，奥地利人
look like they're going to gear up for a war against Serbia. And they all say, yeah, I can understand that. That's fair enough. And actually, the Kaiser's adjutant, who's a guy called Hans von Plessen, he writes a diary, which is a brilliant source for us, gives us a real sense of what they're thinking. Here, the view prevails that
看起来他们要为对塞尔维亚的战争做准备了。他们都说，是的，我能理解。这很公平。而且实际上，德皇的副官，一个叫汉斯·冯·普莱森的人，他写了一本日记，这对我们来说是一个极好的来源，让我们真正了解他们的想法。在这里，普遍的观点是
the sooner the Austrians strike against Serbia, the better. And the Russians,rians strike against Serbia, the better, and the Russians, although friends of Serbia, would not join in after all. So again, the emphasis on speed. Speed, exactly. Now, the key person, really, the Kaiser needs to persuade, if he's keen on this, is the Chancellor. The Chancellor has just got back from his country estate. He is Theobald Bettmann-Holweg.
奥地利人越早对塞尔维亚发动打击越好。而俄国人，虽然是塞尔维亚的朋友，毕竟不会加入。所以再次强调速度。速度，完全正确。现在，如果德皇热衷于此，他真正需要说服的关键人物是总理。总理刚从他的乡间别墅回来。他是特奥巴尔德·冯·贝特曼-霍尔维格。
Now, because he's the leader of Germany and because he's got a beard, he's very easy to caricature as this sort of Mephistopheles figure. Yeah. And he's absolutely not that at all. I mean, he's like all those British ministers whose idea of fun is to go off and read Plato in Greek. That's genuinely what he's been doing. I mean, he genuinely has been reading Plato in Greek. Yeah.
现在，因为他是德国的领导人，而且因为他留着胡子，他很容易被漫画化为这种梅菲斯特式的形象。是的。他根本不是那样的人。我的意思是，他就像所有那些认为乐趣就是去读希腊文柏拉图的英国大臣一样。这确实是他一直在做的事情。我的意思是，他确实一直在读希腊文的柏拉图。是的。
Because his wife has just died after a long illness, Bethmann-Holweg's wife. He's very melancholy, and he's been reading Plato. In Britain, people regarded him as quite an admirable person. He's a moderate conservative. He's not a super reactionary. He's from a Frankfurt kind of law and banking family. Richard Haldane, who'd been Britain's Secretary of State for War in the Edwardian period, said he was the Abraham Lincoln of Germany. You know, an admirable man, measured, sensible, cultured, all of this kind of thing. And Bethlehem Holbeck, said he was the Abraham Lincoln of Germany. An admirable man, measured, sensible, cultured, all of this kind of thing. And Bethlenholweg, when he listens to Kaiser explains what's going on, he says, yeah, I mean, fair enough. We'll stand by the Austrians. That'll
因为他的妻子在长期患病后刚刚去世，贝特曼-霍尔维格的妻子。他非常忧郁，一直在读柏拉图。在英国，人们认为他是一个相当令人钦佩的人。他是一个温和的保守派。他不是一个超级反动派。他来自法兰克福的一个法律和银行家族。理查德·霍尔丹，曾在爱德华时代担任英国战争大臣，说他是德国的亚伯拉罕·林肯。你知道，一个令人钦佩的人，稳重、明智、有教养，所有这类事情。而贝特曼-霍尔维格，当他听德皇解释发生了什么时，他说，是的，我的意思是，很公平。我们会支持奥地利人。这会
work to deter the Russians. Let them have their crack at Serbia. So they're all agreed. The next morning, Monday the 6th, the Kaiser goes off on holiday. And there are some historians who say this is a sign of just how sinister and Machiavellian the Germans are, that they all go on holiday to fool everybody into thinking there's not going to be a world war. I think the Germans don't think there's going to be a world war, and so they go on holiday. And doesn't the Kaiser say, as a reason for thinking this, that the Tsar won't side with the regicides. Yeah, he does.
起到威慑俄国人的作用。让他们对塞尔维亚下手吧。所以他们都同意了。第二天早上，6日星期一，德皇去度假了。有些历史学家说，这表明德国人是多么阴险和马基雅维利，他们都去度假是为了愚弄所有人，让他们认为不会有世界大战。我认为德国人认为不会有世界大战，所以他们去度假了。德皇不是说，认为这一点的理由是沙皇不会站在弑君者一边吗？是的，他说了。
So ultimately, the Russians will kick up a fuss. But because of that detail, because he can't imagine Nikki backing regicides, it will be all right. Absolutely, he thinks that, Tom. I don't think you can make sense of what happens in all this without thinking that the Germans and the Austrians, like the Russians later on, genuinely think they're in the right. They think that virtue and decency and reason are on their side and that the reasonable person will look at their case and say, fair enough. Regicides have
所以最终，俄国人会大惊小怪。但因为那个细节，因为他无法想象尼基支持弑君者，所以一切都会好起来的。绝对，他就是这么想的，汤姆。我认为如果不认为德国人和奥地利人，就像后来的俄国人一样，真诚地认为他们是正义的，你就无法理解这一切中发生的事情。他们认为美德、体面和理性站在他们这一边，理智的人会看他们的案子并说，很公平。弑君者必须
to be punished. Terrorism cannot be allowed to flourish unchecked, all of this kind of thing. Well, we're familiar with that kind of argument, aren't we? Of course we are. Of course we are. So this is effectively the blank check. Right. So this is the famous blank check. Yeah. Because the Chancellor, Bethman, goes to see the ambassador, or they have a meeting, and he says, just to confirm everything the Kaiser has said to you, we will stand behind you, go for it, whatever happens. And it's your call. It's not our call because it's not our business. It is your call. And whatever you decide, we are your friend and we are with you. But Dominic, just to be clear, the Germans
受到惩罚。恐怖主义不能被允许不受限制地滋生，所有这类事情。好吧，我们熟悉那种论点，不是吗？当然我们熟悉。当然我们熟悉。所以这实际上就是空白支票。对。所以这就是著名的空白支票。是的。因为总理贝特曼去见大使，或者他们开了一个会，他说，只是为了确认德皇对你所说的一切，我们会站在你们身后，去吧，无论发生什么。这是你们的决定。这不是我们的决定，因为这不是我们的事。这是你们的决定。无论你们决定什么，我们都是你们的朋友，我们和你们在一起。但多米尼克，明确一点，德国人
basically don't think that they are giving a blank check because they think that this will be a local war. They don't think that they're saying, yeah, we're with you and let's have a world war and brilliant. No, we'll come to this because this is a slightly more complicated issue. Right. And I ask that because probably people listening to this will be aware of something called the Schlieffen Plan. They'll be aware of kind of talk that Germany has been preparing for a war of conquest against France and against Russia and has been embroiled in a naval race against Britain. So should we take a break at this point? And when we come back, let's look at each of those scenarios
基本上不认为他们是在开出一张空白支票，因为他们认为这将是一场局部战争。他们不认为他们是在说，是的，我们和你们在一起，让我们打一场世界大战，太棒了。不，我们会谈到这一点，因为这是一个稍微复杂一点的问题。对。我问这个问题是因为听这个节目的人可能知道所谓的施里芬计划。他们会知道关于德国一直在准备对法国和俄国的征服战争，并且一直卷入与英国的海军竞赛的谈话。那么我们此时应该休息一下吗？当我们回来时，让我们看看每一个场景
and find how accurate they are. Tom, I would love nothing more than to take a break now. And we can talk about this when we come back. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host
并找出它们有多准确。汤姆，我非常乐意现在休息一下。当我们回来时，我们可以谈谈这个。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持
The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com hello welcome back to The Rest Is History.
《娱乐的余味》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com，那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。
Germany has just issued Austria the notorious blank check. And Dominic, often, and I have to say that this is how I've always understood it, that this is essentially the expression of a German establishment that is keen for war. But having reread Christopher Clarke's great book, The Sleepwalkers, in preparation for this, and having read all your notes, I'm now doubtful. Oh, Tom, I hate to be the person who sows doubt in your mind. So can we tease this myth? First of all, Britain.
德国刚刚向奥地利发出了臭名昭著的空白支票。多米尼克，通常，我必须说这就是我一直理解的方式，这本质上是一个渴望战争的德国建制派的表达。但在为这一集准备时重读了克里斯托弗·克拉克的伟大著作《梦游者》，并阅读了你所有的笔记后，我现在怀疑了。哦，汤姆，我讨厌成为那个在你心中播下怀疑种子的人。所以我们能拆解这个神话吗？首先，英国。
Yeah. Because certainly here, the idea that the Kaiser is gagging for war because of various insults that he's received and so on. How accurate is that? There has been Anglo-German antagonism. And when we get onto Britain in this story in a couple of episodes time, we will talk about this in greater detail. But by and large, the general sense in 1914 is that relations haven't been brilliant, but they are now definitely on an upwards curve. We're getting along much better.
是的。因为当然在这里，德皇因为他所受到的各种侮辱而渴望战争的想法。这有多准确？确实存在英德对抗。当我们在一两集后谈到这个故事中的英国时，我们将更详细地讨论这一点。但总的来说，1914年普遍的感觉是关系一直不怎么样，但现在肯定处于上升曲线。我们相处得好多了。
You mentioned Haldane, this guy Haldane, the war minister who had a mission in 1912, hadn't he? Yes. That had been aborted. Yes. There had been efforts going back to the days of Joseph Chamberlain in British politics by people who said, we have a lot in common with the Germans. And actually, they would be a really good natural ally for us. And it just hasn't worked out for various reasons, small things, but also actually, the British don't ultimately think they've got that much to gain from an alliance with Germany compared with an alliance with France and Russia, which
你提到了霍尔丹，这个家伙霍尔丹，那个在1912年有使命的战争大臣，不是吗？是的。那次使命被中止了。是的。英国政界从约瑟夫·张伯伦时代开始，就有人说，我们和德国人有很多共同点。实际上，他们将是我们一个非常好的天然盟友。但由于各种原因，小事情，但实际上，与法国和俄国的联盟相比，英国人最终认为他们从与德国的联盟中得不到那么多好处，这
will solve a lot of problems for them. For reasons that we will see when we get to Britain. Yes. But by and large, most Germans are now working for good relations with Britain. They want good relations. And the Kaiser, I mean, he's going off on his holiday on his yacht. Yeah. And he's going to be hanging out with British officers at regattas, isn't he?
会为他们解决很多问题。原因我们会在谈到英国时看到。是的。但总的来说，大多数德国人现在都在为与英国建立良好关系而努力。他们想要良好的关系。而德皇，我的意思是，他要去他的游艇上度假了。是的。他将和英国军官在帆船赛上聚会，不是吗？
He is. So this is the curious thing with the Kaiser. Nobody in history has ever spoken more of their contempt for Britain than the Kaiser. But at the same time, he desperately wants Britain's admiration, affection, respect, and all those kinds of things. He wants the British to be his friend and to take him seriously. When they don't, he's full of bitterness and anger. But I don't think there was any sense whatsoever. I mean, we will see throughout this story, actually, let's be honest. The last thing that most German policymakers, including people in the military, want is war with Britain because they don't want to have to face the British Navy and the British economy and British industry and
他是。所以这就是德皇奇怪的地方。历史上没有人比德皇表达过更多对英国的蔑视。但与此同时，他极度渴望英国的钦佩、喜爱、尊重和所有这类事情。他希望英国人成为他的朋友并认真对待他。当他们不这样做时，他充满了痛苦和愤怒。但我认为根本没有任何感觉。我的意思是，我们将在这个故事中看到，实际上，让我们诚实一点。大多数德国决策者，包括军方的人，最不想要的就是与英国的战争，因为他们不想面对英国海军、英国经济、英国工业和
the empire and all of that kind of stuff. What is a different story is Russia. Lots of Germans think that war with Russia in the long run is inevitable. So they've grown up in that world of the late 19th century where people talk in terms of races and inevitable racial struggles. So Teutons against Slavs. Teutons against Slavs. And they think, well, this is inevitable. It will come one day. And they think that every day that passes the odds turn more and more against them because russia is this enormous country with a massive army double the size of the german army it's getting bigger all the time but also russia hitherto very backward is modernizing
帝国以及所有这类东西。不同的故事是俄国。许多德国人认为从长远来看，与俄国的战争是不可避免的。所以他们在19世纪末的那个世界里长大，人们用种族和不可避免的种族斗争来谈论。所以条顿人对抗斯拉夫人。条顿人对抗斯拉夫人。他们认为，好吧，这是不可避免的。总有一天会到来。他们认为每一天过去，胜算就越来越不利于他们，因为俄国是一个拥有庞大军队的巨大国家，是德国军队的两倍，而且一直在变大，但俄国迄今为止非常落后，正在现代化、
industrializing building railways rearming all of this stuff to give you a small example in the summer of 1914 the kaiser read an article in a Russian newspaper that had been planted by the Russian war ministry. And it was a boastful article about how they were rearming and how they had all this modern equipment and they were going to have a massive army in a few years' time that would be three times bigger than Germany's army. And he writes in the margin and he says, oh, the Russians have put their cars on the table. He says anybody who thinks that the Russians and their French friends are not planning a war against us should be in a lunatic asylum. Right. So Russia is in alliance with France. Yes. We should just remind people of that as well. Which is why, of course, Tom, the Germans feel encircled because they look West and there's the French, they look East and there's the Russians. So really their only allies, great power allies, is Austria-Hungary. Yeah.
工业化、建设铁路、重新武装，所有这些东西。给你一个小例子，1914年夏天，德皇读了一篇俄国报纸上的文章，那是俄国战争部植入的。那是一篇吹嘘的文章，关于他们如何重新武装，以及他们如何拥有所有这些现代装备，几年后他们将拥有一支比德国军队大三倍的庞大军队。他在页边空白处写道，他说，哦，俄国人把他们的牌放在桌子上了。他说，任何认为俄国人和他们的法国朋友没有计划对我们发动战争的人都应该被关进疯人院。对。所以俄国与法国结盟。是的。我们也应该提醒人们这一点。这就是为什么，当然，汤姆，德国人感到被包围，因为他们向西看，那里有法国人，他们向东看，那里有俄国人。所以实际上他们唯一的盟友，大国盟友，是奥匈帝国。是的。
And even with the Austria-Hungarian army, they're still outnumbered by the Russians on their own and excluding France, let alone Britain. I'm glad you raised that point because, of course, what that tells you is that's one reason why they issued that blank check. Because they have only one real reliable friend. If you have only one friend and you don't stand by that one friend, then you have no friends. Right. And this, of course, will be a consideration for Britain in relation to France. Of course. So these are also for Britain in relation to France. Of course. So these are also important factors in explaining what happens.
即使有奥匈帝国军队，他们仍然被俄国人以数量优势压倒，更不用说法国，更不用说英国了。我很高兴你提出了这一点，因为当然，这告诉你为什么他们发出了那张空白支票。因为他们只有一个真正可靠的朋友。如果你只有一个朋友，而你不支持那个朋友，那么你就没有朋友了。对。当然，这对英国与法国的关系也是一个考虑因素。当然。所以这些也是解释发生的事情的重要因素。
Yes, absolutely. To me, the really striking thing about the Germans before 1914, there is a lot of strutting and a lot of spikes on helmets and all that sort of stuff. But actually, the really striking thing is the general mood is one of pessimism and melancholy and a kind of fatalism. So Bethman Holbeck, the chancellor, one of his aides, there's an incredible diary entry just a few days later, 7th of July. And he says, yesterday I was with the Reich chancellor.
是的，绝对。对我来说，1914年前德国人真正引人注目的是，有很多昂首阔步，头盔上有很多尖刺，所有这类东西。但实际上，真正引人注目的是普遍的情绪是一种悲观、忧郁和一种宿命论。所以贝特曼-霍尔维格，总理，他的一个助手，几天后有一篇令人难以置信的日记条目，7月7日。他说，昨天我和帝国总理在一起。
We were in his old chateau, the great trees. There's a massive sense he hasn't got over his wife's death and melancholy and a restraint in landscape and people. And he says they talked about the world situation. Russia's military power growing rapidly. Austria continually weakening and more immobile. Austria, our last decent ally. In general, blindness all around, a thick fog over the people. The future belongs to Russia, which grows and grows and becomes for us an ever more oppressive nightmare. And so I know that this is very complicated and that
我们在他的老城堡里，大树。有一种巨大的感觉，他还没有从妻子的去世中走出来，忧郁，景观和人们的克制。他说他们谈到了世界局势。俄国的军事力量迅速增长。奥地利不断削弱且更加僵化。奥地利，我们最后一个像样的盟友。总的来说，到处都是盲目，人们头顶上有一层浓雾。未来属于俄国，它不断增长，成为我们一个越来越压抑的噩梦。所以我知道这非常复杂，而且
lots of historians now say that there was no such thing, but the Schlieffen plan, this idea that there should be a rapid war against France to knock France out, and then you turn your forces and go to Russia. And that this kind of rapid war, because you have to bring France to defeat very early, would necessitate the German army moving through Belgium. Is this a thing? Are they talking about it? Are they preparing for it? Because that's very much, I think, the vague sense that people might have in their heads. It's a complicated question. But the first thing to say is everybody has plans. So the French have plans. You have bureaucratized militaries in a way that you maybe didn't have
现在有很多历史学家说根本没有这样的事情，但施里芬计划，这种应该对法国进行快速战争以击败法国，然后你转向你的部队去俄国。而且这种快速战争，因为你必须很早就击败法国，将需要德国军队穿过比利时。这是真的吗？他们在谈论它吗？他们在为它做准备吗？因为我认为这非常像是人们脑海中可能有的模糊感觉。这是一个复杂的问题。但首先要说的是每个人都有计划。所以法国人有计划。你有官僚化的军队，以一种你可能没有的方式
a hundred years earlier, where they have exercises, they have maneuvers, they have very complicated strategies and tactics that they have worked out. Warfare has become intellectualized, I guess. And as a result of that, they do have war scenarios and plans drawn up. And obviously, if you are the Germans, you have to fight one of those two people first, either France or Russia. And their sense is France is the more dangerous adversary because it's much more industrialized and much more modern.
一百年前，他们有演习，他们有演习，他们有非常复杂的战略和战术。战争已经变得知识化了，我想。结果，他们确实制定了战争场景和计划。显然，如果你是德国人，你必须先与那两个人中的一个作战，要么是法国，要么是俄国。他们的感觉是法国是更危险的对手，因为它更工业化，更现代。
Deal with them first. And then we turn back to this great lumbering leviathan. Behemoth in the east. Yeah, of Russia in the east. But basically, if we've already knocked out France, we just do what we can then on the eastern front, and eventually we'll beat the Russians. And that's the way of doing it. Are they planning to launch this plan?
先对付他们。然后我们转向这个在东方巨大的笨重利维坦。巨兽。是的，在东方的俄国。但基本上，如果我们已经击败了法国，我们就在东线尽我们所能，最终我们会打败俄国人。这就是做法。他们计划启动这个计划吗？
Are they itching to get started? I think that is the wrong way of looking at it, because they are so gloomy. And a lot of them, when they talk about a future war, which they do all the time, the German generals, they think a war is coming. But when they talk about it, they're not, what are you going to wear at the victory parade for it? No, there's this incredible vein of fatalism. I mean, it amazed me reading all these German generals when they talk about the prospect of war. And they do kind of say, yeah, it's inevitable, we're going to have to have it. But they're not doing it really in any tone of triumphalism. It's kind of, we're probably going to be defeated and annihilated, but it's better to go down fighting
他们急于开始吗？我认为那是错误的看待方式，因为他们太忧郁了。他们中的许多人，当他们谈论未来的战争时，他们一直在谈论，德国将军们，他们认为战争即将来临。但当他们谈论它时，他们不是，你在胜利游行时要穿什么？不，有一种令人难以置信的宿命论。我的意思是，读所有这些德国将军谈论战争前景时，我感到惊讶。他们确实说，是的，这是不可避免的，我们必须打。但他们并不是以任何胜利主义的语气这样做。这是一种，我们可能会被击败和歼灭，但最好是战斗到底
kind of tone. Yeah, I think so. Because they're looking all the time at Russia and they're thinking, you know, the time to fight the Russians was 1890 or something. In 1920, the Russians will be so much more industrialized and they'll have fantastic railways and the French will lend them all this money to buy new guns and stuff. And if there is, as they think, an inevitable racial conflict coming between Teuton and Slav, they think there's a lot more Slavs than there are us. And the law of nature is struggle and we're for the chop. So at this point, are there members of the German staff who think this is a chance to beat Russia while we have the opportunity?
那种语气。是的，我想是这样。因为他们一直在看着俄国，他们认为，你知道，与俄国人作战的时间是1890年左右。在1920年，俄国人将更加工业化，他们将拥有梦幻般的铁路，法国人将借给他们所有的钱去买新枪之类的东西。如果正如他们所想的那样，条顿人和斯拉夫人之间不可避免的种族冲突即将来临，他们认为斯拉夫人比我们多得多。自然的法则就是斗争，我们注定要倒霉。所以此时，德国参谋部里有成员认为这是在有机会时打败俄国的机会吗？
If we leave it a few more years, then, you know, we'll be doomed. We might as well crack on. Again, a complicated question, Tom. Sorry to give you a very nuanced answer because I know we hate nuanced answers on The Rest Is History. No, I love that answer. Well, here's the thing. What do they think will happen? Some of them think the Austrians won't actually follow through with this. So I mentioned Erich von Falkenhayn, who later becomes the German
如果我们再留几年，那么，你知道，我们就完了。我们不如开始吧。同样，一个复杂的问题，汤姆。很抱歉给你一个非常细致的回答，因为我知道我们在《历史的余味》中讨厌细致的回答。不，我喜欢那个回答。好吧，事情是这样的。他们认为会发生什么？他们中的一些人认为奥地利人实际上不会坚持到底。所以我提到了埃里希·冯·法尔肯海恩，他后来成为了德国
kind of supreme commander for a brief time in the First World War. Falkenhayn says, you know, the Austrians are all talk, but ultimately, you know, it's all just cakes and Mozart with them. They're not going to follow through with this. Then most of the people think the Austrians will actually follow through this time, but the Russians won't join in. Now, there are some people who say, I mean, they're not idiots, right? They think there's always a chance the Russians might join in. But they say, well, listen, if that happens, there is no better time than now. So you can understand the logic of that. In our own lives, we will have had situations where we say, I don't really want this to
在第一次世界大战期间曾短暂担任最高统帅。法尔肯海恩说，你知道，奥地利人只会夸夸其谈，但归根结底，对他们来说，这一切不过是蛋糕和莫扎特。他们不会把这件事贯彻到底。当时大多数人都认为奥地利人这次会真的贯彻到底，但俄国人不会加入。现在，有些人会说，我的意思是，他们又不是傻瓜，对吧？他们认为俄国人总是有可能加入的。但他们说，好吧，听着，如果真的发生了，现在就是最好的时机。所以你可以理解其中的逻辑。在我们自己的生活中，我们也会遇到这样的情况，我们会说，我真的不想让这件事
happen, but if it is going to happen, well, better to do it now than to do it later. It's a little bit like that stupid thing that people say when you're in a football tournament and you say, well, we don't want to draw Brazil in the second round. And then somebody says, yeah, but you've got to play them at some point, haven't you? Better to play them early on. That's the way they think about the Russians. We don't really want to be drawn against them, but we've got to play them at some point. So why not now?
发生，但如果它注定要发生，那么，早做总比晚做好。这有点像人们在参加足球锦标赛时说的那些蠢话，你说，好吧，我们不想在第二轮抽到巴西队。然后有人说，是啊，但你迟早得和他们踢，不是吗？早点踢总比晚点踢好。他们就是这样看待俄国人的。我们真的不想抽到他们，但我们迟早得和他们踢。那为什么不是现在呢？
Let's just do it. And I think they think if the Russians do get stuck in now, that will prove that they hate us and they were always going to do that. So it's better to do it now, actually. But it's a defensive mentality, even though they're planning a war of aggression. And this is a paradox that runs throughout the build-up to the outbreak of the war. Yeah, it's such a good point. And actually, we've done obviously series about the rise of the Nazis.
干脆就现在吧。我想他们认为，如果俄国人现在卷入其中，那就证明他们恨我们，而且他们本来就打算这么做。所以实际上，现在动手更好。但这是一种防御心态，尽管他们正在策划一场侵略战争。这是一个贯穿战争爆发前夕的悖论。是的，这观点太好了。事实上，我们显然已经做过关于纳粹崛起的系列节目。
And I don't think you understand the mentality in Germany after the war unless you realise that the Germans genuinely thought they were fighting a defensive war. I mean, all their rhetoric when the war starts is, we have been forced to draw the sword. We didn't want to. We are surrounded. That sense that you mentioned of being encircled and the Schlieffen plan is their way out, that's massively, massively important to them and their sense of right being on their side. Nobody whatsoever, really, in Germany in the Great War thinks we are the bad guys in this war. They think it's been forced upon them by a malevolent Russia. Anyway, at this point, they don't think there is going to be a
我不认为你能理解战后德国人的心态，除非你意识到德国人真心认为他们是在进行一场防御性战争。我的意思是，战争开始时他们所有的言论都是，我们是被迫拔剑的。我们不想这样。我们被包围了。你提到的那种被包围的感觉，以及施里芬计划是他们的出路，这对他们以及他们认为自己站在正义一方的感觉来说，是非常、非常重要的。在第一次世界大战中，德国真的没有任何人认为我们是这场战争中的坏人。他们认为这是被邪恶的俄国强加给他们的。总之，在这一点上，他们当然不认为会发生
world war, of course. Falkenhayn says to Wilhelm, Wilhelm's bags are packed and he's about to go off. He's got his yachting shoes and he's got all his stuff. And he says, shall I make some preparations just in case? And Wilhelm explicitly says, no, preparations for what? There isn't going to be a war. So off he goes on his Baltic cruise. Bethlehem, the Chancellor, he goes back to his country estate to kind of stroll and think about Plato. General von Moltke has spent the whole time surrounded by hideous sulfuric waters.
世界大战。法尔肯海恩对威廉说，威廉的行李已经打包好了，他正准备出发。他带上了他的游艇鞋和所有的东西。他说，我需要做些准备以防万一吗？威廉明确表示，不，准备什么？不会有战争的。于是他就去进行他的波罗的海巡游了。贝特曼，那位首相，他回到自己的乡间庄园去散步，思考柏拉图。小毛奇将军则一直待在令人作呕的硫磺水域中。
Large men slapping his shoulders. Exactly. Terrible scenes. Probably the worst scenes in this whole series of a German spa. So now some people would say, all very cunning from the Germans, of course. They're lulling everybody into it. But I don't think that's right at all. I think they genuinely don't think this is going to lead to a conflagration.
大块头的人拍着他的肩膀。没错。可怕的场景。这可能是整个系列中最糟糕的德国温泉场景。所以现在有些人会说，这当然是德国人非常狡猾的表现。他们是在麻痹所有人。但我认为这根本不对。我认为他们真心不认为这会导致一场大火。
Hoyos returns and the ambassador telegraphs back to Vienna. And the people in Vienna, they think this is absolutely brilliant, of course, because they've got the blank check. Do what you like. You know, we're not even going to try and influence you. A lot of historians would say, very irresponsible of the Germans to give the Austrians this blank check. But for Berchtold and General Conrad, they say, tremendous. Shall we crack on and do it? But they can't, can they? Because it's Austro-Hungary and everything takes eight months to do anything. Exactly. I mean, this is the weird thing, right? So Thomas Otte in his book, July Crisis,
霍约斯回来了，大使发电报回维也纳。维也纳的人当然认为这太棒了，因为他们拿到了空白支票。想做什么就做什么。你知道，我们甚至不会试图影响你们。许多历史学家会说，德国人给奥地利人这张空白支票是非常不负责任的。但对于贝希托尔德和康拉德将军来说，他们说，太棒了。我们要不要赶紧行动起来？但他们做不到，不是吗？因为这是奥匈帝国，做任何事情都要花八个月的时间。没错。我的意思是，这很奇怪，对吧？所以托马斯·奥特在他的书《七月危机》中，
he is quite old school and he blames the Austrians and the Germans for the First World War. But even in this book, he says, listen, if they had attacked Serbia, you know, the next day, there would have been no world war. Would they have been in a position to do that though? No, they're disorganized. So it's an irrelevant argument, isn't it? I suppose it is. But it makes the point that a shock has happened. And for the Austrians, the shock doesn't really fade. They are still nursing their sense of hurt.
他非常守旧，他把第一次世界大战归咎于奥地利人和德国人。但即使在这本书里，他也说，听着，如果他们第二天就进攻塞尔维亚，就不会有世界大战了。但他们当时有能力那样做吗？不，他们组织混乱。所以这是一个无关紧要的论点，不是吗？我想是这样。但这说明了一个问题，那就是冲击已经发生了。对于奥地利人来说，这种冲击并没有真正消退。他们仍然沉浸在受伤的感觉中。
But for everybody else, it has faded. Now, their whole system, as you said, it's not just that it's slow by accident. It is built by design to be slow because the whole basis of Austria-Hungary is a massive compromise. It's a compromise largely between Austria and Hungary, but also they have to take into account the Croats and the Slovenes and the Ukrainians and the Poles and all these other people in their empire. So everything proceeds in a very, very nuanced, negotiated, kind of conflict-avoiding, bureaucratic way. That's the
但对其他人来说，这种冲击已经消退了。现在，他们的整个系统，正如你所说，不仅仅是偶然的缓慢。它是被设计成缓慢的，因为奥匈帝国的整个基础是一个巨大的妥协。这主要是在奥地利和匈牙利之间的妥协，但他们也必须考虑到克罗地亚人、斯洛文尼亚人、乌克兰人、波兰人以及帝国中的所有其他人。所以一切都以一种非常、非常微妙、经过协商、某种避免冲突的官僚方式进行。这就是
way it works. It's a bit like the EU or something. And as a result of that, they meet on the 7th of July, and they still don't make a decision because the Hungarian prime minister, who we talked about last time, Istvan Tisza, he is still very reluctant. And he says, actually, do you know what? I know the Germans are kind of up for this, but I still think it would be better to humiliate Serbia diplomatically. And the Kaiser's option of just occupying Belgrade, everyone's forgotten about that by this point. No, this hasn't been raised at this point. So the Kaiser will bring that up later on. He'll say, why do you have to have a huge war? Why don't you just make a punitive expedition? And do you know what? The Kaiser gets, he doesn't always get a lot of respect
它的运作方式。这有点像欧盟之类的。结果就是，他们在7月7日开会，但仍然没有做出决定，因为我们上次提到的匈牙利首相伊斯特万·蒂萨仍然非常不情愿。他说，说实话，你知道吗？我知道德国人对此很感兴趣，但我仍然认为通过外交手段羞辱塞尔维亚会更好。而皇帝提出的直接占领贝尔格莱德的方案，到这个时候大家都已经忘记了。不，这一点在此时还没有被提出来。所以皇帝稍后会提到这一点。他会说，你们为什么非要打一场大规模的战争？为什么不只进行一次惩罚性远征呢？你知道吗？皇帝得到的，虽然他在
in this podcast, but this is probably the best idea the Kaiser ever had. But people ignore it. People think he's just being mad again. Yes, exactly.
这个播客中并不总是得到很多尊重，但这可能是皇帝有过的最好的主意。但人们忽略了它。人们认为他只是又疯了。是的，没错。
Exactly. Well, I have some sympathy with that. Those Hohenzollern parallels again. Just an endless stream of brilliant ideas that have dogged you ever since you started this podcast.
没错。好吧，我对此深表同情。又是那些霍亨索伦家族的相似之处。自从你开始这个播客以来，无数绝妙的主意一直困扰着你。
Yeah. Right. So on the 8th of July, we're now well over a week since the assassination, the Austrians draw up a new plan that they think will basically persuade Count Tisza, the Hungarian prime minister. And they say, look, here's what we'll do. We won't just attack Serbia. We will give them an ultimatum listing all our
是啊。好吧。所以到了7月8日，距离暗杀事件已经过去一周多了，奥地利人制定了一个新计划，他们认为这基本上能说服匈牙利首相蒂萨伯爵。他们说，看，我们这样做。我们不会只攻击塞尔维亚。我们会给他们发最后通牒，列出我们所有的
grievances and we will make an ultimatum, and I quote, with demands that Serbia can scarcely be willing to fulfill. Then either war or such a humiliation for Serbia that she is eliminated as a factor for some time. In other words, we'll give them this ultimatum and they won't accept it. If they do accept it, they'll be completely humiliated. And if they don't accept it, we can strike them then. And do you know what? Still, they don't do anything. Still, the days go by because Tisa is now making up his mind. And he's like, oh, I'll think about it. And he thinks about it for almost another week until finally on the 14th of July. So we are now more than two weeks after the assassination, he goes to see the German ambassador and he says, well, I've made up my mind.
不满，我们会发出最后通牒，引用原文，“提出塞尔维亚几乎不可能满足的要求”。要么战争，要么让塞尔维亚受到如此羞辱，以至于它在一段时间内被排除在因素之外。换句话说，我们会给他们这个最后通牒，他们不会接受。如果他们接受了，他们就会被彻底羞辱。如果他们不接受，我们就可以在那时打击他们。你知道吗？他们仍然什么都没做。日子一天天过去，因为蒂萨现在还在拿主意。他就像，哦，我会考虑一下的。他考虑了几乎又一周，直到7月14日。所以我们现在距离暗杀事件已经过去两周多了，他去见德国大使，他说，好吧，我决定了。
Let's do this. So you think, finally. Do they go for it? No, of course not. They're actually hungry. Oh. Of course they don't do it. So now they have two other issues.
我们干吧。所以你以为，终于。他们要行动了吗？不，当然没有。他们实际上在收获庄稼。哦。他们当然没做。所以现在他们有两个其他问题。
One is their railway network is not built for swift mobilization. So at some point, I think they said to Conrad, well, great, you've been asking for this war for so long. When would you like to start it? He's like, 1916? Does it have to be this decade? So Dominic, just on the issue of mobilization, important to talk about this because obviously this affects all the various competence in the war. There are two issues really, aren't there? So there's the railways and A.J.P. Taylor said it happens because the railway timetables can't be changed. And the other thing is it's July, it's coming up to August and this is harvest time. And so that is a real problem if you're doing a mass mobilisation that you may risk the harvest. Absolutely a massive issue, Tom. And both those things are really important. In an age of partially mechanized, industrialized warfare, you need to get your men to the front.
一个是他们的铁路网不是为快速动员而建的。所以有一次，我想他们对康拉德说，好吧，太棒了，你一直要求这场战争这么久。你想什么时候开始？他说，1916年？一定要在这个十年吗？所以多米尼克，就动员问题而言，谈论这一点很重要，因为这显然影响了战争中的所有参战国。实际上有两个问题，不是吗？一个是铁路，A.J.P.泰勒说这是因为铁路时刻表无法更改。另一件事是现在是七月，快到八月了，这是收获季节。所以如果你进行大规模动员，你可能会冒着影响收获的风险，这是一个真正的问题。绝对是一个巨大的问题，汤姆。这两件事都非常重要。在半机械化、工业化战争的时代，你需要把你的士兵送到前线。
And you cannot afford to do that after somebody else. If they're at the front and you aren't, and you're trudging along the lanes, curtains, you're beaten. So mobilizing your men, which means basically getting them moving, getting them to the front lines, is massively, massively important. If you are Germany, let's say, and you're looking at that massive Russian army much bigger than yours, speed is the essence for you. You can't hang around, as we'll see later on. The issue of the timetables and people going the wrong way on the network and all that stuff, that's actually really important. If you've set your army in train to basically commandeer the whole network and sending them off to the west, you can't then suddenly say,
而且你负担不起在别人之后才这样做。如果他们在前线而你不在，而你还在小路上蹒跚而行，完了，你就输了。所以动员你的士兵，这意味着基本上让他们行动起来，把他们送到前线，是非常、非常重要的。如果你是德国，假设你看着那支比你大得多的庞大俄国军队，速度对你来说就是本质。你不能拖延，正如我们稍后会看到的。时刻表的问题以及人们在网络上走错路等等，实际上非常重要。如果你已经让你的军队开始基本上征用整个网络并把他们送到西部，你不能突然说，
oh, actually, I've changed my mind. Oh, let's send them east. I mean, that's not how trains work. But also you can see why a mobilization that precedes the mobilization of a potential adversary might be seen as a defensive measure by the person who's doing it. Of course. And we're mobilizing just in case. But of course, if your opponent mobilises just in case, you can't not mobilise yourself, because what if they then attack you? So it's kind of a doomsday machine. It is. Exactly that. Now, as you said, the other thing about the harvest, Austria-Hungary is a farming country, vast tracts of farms dominated by these big landowners and magnates who are often involved in politics. And they have basically persuaded the army to give their men farming leave so that in the summer,
哦，实际上，我改变主意了。哦，让我们把他们送到东部去。我的意思是，火车不是那样运作的。但你也可以看出，为什么先于潜在对手的动员可能会被执行者视为一种防御措施。当然。我们动员只是以防万一。但当然，如果你的对手以防万一进行了动员，你不能不进行动员，因为如果他们随后攻击你怎么办？所以这有点像末日机器。确实。正是如此。现在，正如你所说，关于收获的另一件事，奥匈帝国是一个农业国家，大片农场由这些经常参与政治的大地主和权贵所控制。他们基本上说服了军队给他们的士兵放农忙假，这样在夏天，
they'll all go back to their hometowns and they're helped with the harvest. And right now, Conrad says, everyone's like, great, finally we can do it. And he says, yeah, there is just one thing actually. So a lot of big places in the empire, Zagreb, Br budapest krakow the soldiers have all gone home and they won't be back until the end of july now he could recall them now but if he did that everybody in europe would know that there's going to be a war so he doesn't want to do that because that kind of gives the game away and what is worse they work out that the end of the harvest leave kind of overlaps with a visit, a state visit, by the leaders of France to St. Petersburg between the 20th and the 23rd of July. And if they attack
他们都会回到家乡，帮助收获。而现在，康拉德说，每个人都像，太棒了，终于可以做了。他说，是的，实际上只有一件事。所以帝国里的许多大地方，萨格勒布、布达佩斯、克拉科夫，士兵们都回家了，直到七月底才会回来。现在他可以召回他们，但如果他那样做了，欧洲的每个人都会知道要发生战争了，所以他不想那样做，因为那会泄露天机。更糟糕的是，他们算出收获假结束的时间与法国领导人在7月20日至23日期间对圣彼得堡的国事访问重叠。如果他们在那时攻击
Serbia then, then Serbia's best pals will be together in St. Petersburg and will be able to coordinate their response perfectly. So from the Austrian point of view, that's obviously bonkers. You don't want to cause a great hullabaloo when they are actually having a summit, as it were, the French and the Russians, because they will be offended by it, but also they'll react to it straight away then and there. So they say, okay, well, fine, we'll have to get everybody back from the harvest. Then we'll have to wait for the French to leave St. Petersburg. So actually, now that we look at it, the Thursday, the 23rd of July,
塞尔维亚，那么塞尔维亚最好的伙伴们就会在圣彼得堡聚在一起，并能够完美地协调他们的反应。所以从奥地利的观点来看，这显然是疯了。当法国人和俄国人实际上在举行峰会时，你不想引起轩然大波，因为他们会因此感到被冒犯，而且他们会当场立即做出反应。所以他们说，好吧，没问题，我们得把所有人都从农忙假中召回来。然后我们得等法国人离开圣彼得堡。所以实际上，现在我们看来，7月23日星期四，
which is the day the French leave St. Petersburg and the troops will be back from the harvest, that's when we'll deliver the ultimatum. So basically, by this point, everyone else has forgotten about assassination. Of course. We know how the news cycle works. It's no different in 1914. A month afterwards, it will almost be exactly a month that they'll give them the ultimatum. A month afterwards, that's yesterday's news. So there's the issue that it's delayed and they've lost all the shock and the speed. The other thing that is absolutely astounding, even though I'm a bit of an Austrophile and
也就是法国人离开圣彼得堡、部队从收获中回来的那一天，就是我们发出最后通牒的时候。所以基本上，到这个时候，其他人都已经忘记了暗杀事件。当然。我们知道新闻周期是如何运作的。1914年也没什么不同。一个月后，几乎正好是一个月，他们才会给他们最后通牒。一个月后，那是昨天的新闻了。所以存在延迟的问题，他们失去了所有的冲击力和速度。另一件绝对令人震惊的事情是，尽管我有点奥地利迷和
a Habsburgophile. Are you, Dominic? Yeah. I hadn't noticed. Love a Sasha Torta, Tom. I love the music of Marla. Can I just say how thrilled I am to learn from your notes that Berktold's private Viennese mansion was called the Strudelhof?
哈布斯堡迷。你是吗，多米尼克？是啊。我没注意到。我喜欢萨赫蛋糕，汤姆。我喜欢马勒的音乐。我能说一下我从你的笔记中得知贝希托尔德在维也纳的私人宅邸叫“斯特鲁德尔霍夫”有多激动吗？
I know. I mean, that seems so improbable. What I love about this whole story is that everybody behaves. According to every stereotype going. The Kaiser is sort of blustering, crying and shouting at various points. When we introduced the British. They're all fishing. Or playing bridge or something.
我知道。我的意思是，这看起来太不可思议了。关于整个故事，我喜欢的是每个人都表现得符合所有的刻板印象。皇帝在某些时候咆哮、哭泣和喊叫。当我们介绍英国人时。他们都在钓鱼。或者打桥牌之类的。
Yeah. The French are just behaving in a Machiavellian way, but there's also enormous amounts of stress with the French about their cuisine. Yes, yes. And about the details of banquets. The soup. The soup is the wrong soup. Yeah.
是啊。法国人只是以马基雅维利的方式行事，但法国人对他们的美食也有巨大的压力。是的，是的。还有关于宴会的细节。汤。汤是错误的汤。是啊。
All this stuff. And of course, the Austrians all live in the strudelhoff and have ridiculous names so so the question with the austrians right is do they not think that this could go horribly wrong and the weird thing is in all these meetings we don't forget they've had like a billion meetings about this where they decided nothing but as chris clark says in the sleepwalkers they never ever really talk about what will happen if the russians attack them even if the russians don't attack do they have a kind of an end game? No, they have no exit strategy. I mean, you know, George W. Bush, take note.
所有这些东西。当然，奥地利人都住在斯特鲁德尔霍夫，名字也很荒谬。所以关于奥地利人的问题是，他们不认为这可能会变得非常糟糕吗？奇怪的是，在所有这些会议中，别忘了他们已经开了十亿次关于这个的会议，但什么都没决定。正如克里斯·克拉克在《梦游者》中所说，他们从来没有真正讨论过如果俄国人攻击他们会发生什么。即使俄国人不攻击，他们有某种终局计划吗？不，他们没有退出策略。我的意思是，你知道，乔治·W·布什，请注意。
They have no plan for what will happen when it's over. So they still haven't really agreed what they will do with Serbia. Tisza, the Hungarian guy, is still very much against annexing it. But as we've seen, there are other people like Count Hoyos who are like, let's actually partition Serbia and take bits of it for ourselves. By the way, this is all predicated
他们没有计划当这一切结束时会发生什么。所以他们仍然没有真正商定他们将如何处理塞尔维亚。匈牙利人蒂萨仍然非常反对吞并它。但正如我们所见，还有其他人像霍约斯伯爵那样，想要瓜分塞尔维亚，并为自己夺取一部分。顺便说一句，这一切都是基于
on the idea that the Austrians will smash Serbia. And actually, we won't really get into this in this series. But actually, when the Austrians
奥地利人会粉碎塞尔维亚的想法。实际上，我们在这个系列中不会真正深入探讨这一点。但实际上，当奥地利人
do attack Serbia, they are utterly humiliated and forced back into Austria. Although in the long run, Serbia loses more than anybody. Yeah. But I mean, that's down to the fact that the Germans have to bail out the Austrians as
确实攻击塞尔维亚时，他们被彻底羞辱并被迫撤回奥地利。尽管从长远来看，塞尔维亚损失的比任何人都多。是啊。但我的意思是，这归结于德国人必须拯救奥地利人，
much as anything. Anyway, Chris Clark has this wonderful line. It says, the Austrians resembled hedgehogs scurrying across a highway with their eyes averted from the onrushing traffic. Because often when they're having these discussions, it's like, have they forgotten that Russia exists? Because they're not even mentioning it at all. And how do you explain that? One possibility
就像其他任何事情一样。总之，克里斯·克拉克有一句精彩的话。他说，奥地利人就像在高速公路上匆忙穿行的刺猬，眼睛避开了迎面而来的车流。因为通常当他们进行这些讨论时，就像是，他们忘记了俄国的存在吗？因为他们根本没有提到它。你如何解释这一点？一种可能性
is that they're so dazzled by Germany's military prowess that they think the Russians would never dare. And you can sort of see in the Cold War, client states of the United States or the Soviet Union might think that about their own patron. Cuba might think that about the USSR in the 1960s. No one will dare mess with us. Not incorrectly. Yeah, because we've got a very powerful friend. And I think an important thing with the Austrians, I think a lot of them genuinely think they have nothing to lose. That fatalism that we talked about the Germans is in their soul as well.
是他们被德国的军事实力所迷惑，以至于他们认为俄国人永远不敢。你可以看到在冷战中，美国或苏联的附庸国可能会那样看待他们自己的赞助人。古巴在20世纪60年代可能会那样看待苏联。没人敢惹我们。并非不正确。是啊，因为我们有一个非常强大的朋友。我认为奥地利人的一个重要点是，我认为他们中的许多人真心认为他们没有什么可失去的。我们谈到的德国人的那种宿命论也在他们的灵魂中。
They think their empire is in danger of breaking up. They just think if we don't do this now, what's the point? We might as well just leave the game. But also Chris Clark makes this point. And I think it's, again, as I've said before, I don't think it's one that a lot of historians appreciate enough. The Austrians are so convinced that they are right, they just think, this point that you made, the Tsar, why would he support regicide terrorists? Sure, the Russians have different interests from us, but they will surely recognize the
他们认为他们的帝国有解体的危险。他们只是认为如果我们现在不这样做，还有什么意义？我们还不如直接退出游戏。但克里斯·克拉克也提出了这一点。我认为，正如我之前所说，我不认为很多历史学家足够欣赏这一点。奥地利人如此确信他们是正确的，他们只是认为，你提出的这一点，沙皇，他为什么要支持弑君恐怖分子？当然，俄国人有与我们不同的利益，但他们肯定会承认
heir to our throne and his wife have been shot in cold blood. Of course, the Russians will eventually say, yeah, fair enough. And if they do turn out to be terrorist-loving monsters, then the Germans will just deal with them. So actually, we don't need to give them any thoughts at all. And in fact, I mean, unbelievably, they basically leave their eastern border undefended against the Russians because they're just like, well, yeah, let's not even think about that. Let's just concentrate on Serbia. What's the worst that could go wrong? We could lose our entire empire. The dynasty breaks up and it's all been for nothing.
我们的王位继承人和他的妻子被冷血枪杀。当然，俄国人最终会说，是的，有道理。如果他们确实证明是热爱恐怖主义的怪物，那么德国人就会处理他们。所以实际上，我们根本不需要给他们任何考虑。事实上，我的意思是，令人难以置信的是，他们基本上让他们的东部边界对俄国人毫无防备，因为他们只是觉得，好吧，是的，我们甚至不要考虑那个。让我们只专注于塞尔维亚。最坏的情况会怎样？我们可能会失去整个帝国。王朝解体，一切都白费了。
Yeah. But they don't really envisage that. So on the 21st of July, Berchtold and Count Hoyos, they go to Bad Ischl, which is the sort of nice lakeside resort. Is there a spa? Almost certainly there'll be a spa, Tom. Yeah. It's probably one of those places where there's a big casino and a promenade. You know, people are strolling with parasols.
是啊。但他们并没有真正预见到这一点。所以7月21日，贝希托尔德和霍约斯伯爵，他们去了巴德伊舍，那是一个不错的湖畔度假胜地。有温泉吗？几乎可以肯定会有温泉，汤姆。是啊。这可能是一个有大赌场和长廊的地方。你知道，人们撑着遮阳伞散步。
Concert halls. Yeah, absolutely. The faint strains of violins drifting across the lake. A Johann Strauss waltz. Yeah. That's exactly what it is. You told me when we first were going to do this series, Tom, I don't want to give the game away on the inside,
音乐厅。是啊，绝对的。小提琴微弱的旋律在湖面上飘荡。约翰·施特劳斯的圆舞曲。是啊。那正是它的样子。你第一次告诉我要做这个系列时，汤姆，我不想泄露“历史的其余部分”内部的
machinations of the rest is history, but you wanted to make it 28 episodes, was it? I did. Yes, I did. So this is my Kaiser-esque plan. We'd focus on the politics, but we didn't leave it with episodes called A Riding School in Vienna or A Cricket Match at Hove.
阴谋，但你想让它有28集，是吗？我是这么想的。是的，我是这么想的。所以这是我的皇帝式计划。我们会专注于政治，但我们不会留下名为《维也纳的骑术学校》或《霍夫的板球比赛》的剧集。
Yeah. Little vignettes of the life that is about to be lost. I still think that would have been fun. Well, I mean, you've got it now, right? No. People are waltzing on the shores of Bad Ischow. Could have had a whole episode on this. But Dominic, like the German military staff that he is, overruled me, the headstrong Kaiser.
是啊。即将失去的生活的小片段。我仍然认为那会很有趣。好吧，我的意思是，你现在有了，对吧？不。人们在巴德伊舍的岸边跳华尔兹。本可以有一整集关于这个的。但多米尼克，就像他那样的德国军事参谋一样，否决了我，那个固执的皇帝。
There was no blank check there, Tom. It's fair to say so anyway as the last strains of anton brookner are dying away in the distance they hand over the ultimatum to the emperor and we will describe the ultimatum in a subsequent episode and franz joseph says when he sees it he says it's actually quite harsh like it's really harsh and he says to them right then and there there's no way the Russians will tolerate this. You know, this is very, very harsh. But then in that Austrian way, he says, yeah, but let's forget about the Russians.
那里没有空白支票，汤姆。可以这么说，总之，当安东·布鲁克纳的最后旋律在远处消逝时，他们把最后通牒交给了皇帝，我们将在随后的剧集中描述最后通牒，弗朗茨·约瑟夫看到它时说，他说这实际上相当严厉，就像它真的很严厉。他对他们说，就在那时，俄国人不可能容忍这一点。你知道，这非常、非常严厉。但随后以那种奥地利人的方式，他说，是啊，但让我们忘记俄国人吧。
Ah, it's crack on. Whatever. Let's do it anyway. Berchtold said in his diary, the emperor was fully alive to the profound seriousness, even the tragedy of the current historical moment. But what an ironic line that is, because of course they have no idea, Tom, of just how serious and just how tragic that moment would turn out to be. Right. Well, another brilliant episode, Dominic. Thank you. And we will find out what happens next on the road to war in our third episode when we'll be looking at views from russia and from france so not as planned a boating party in berlin which was your original plan for episode no we
啊，赶紧行动吧。不管怎样。无论如何都要做。贝希托尔德在他的日记中说，皇帝完全意识到当前历史时刻的深刻严肃性，甚至是悲剧性。但那是一句多么讽刺的话啊，因为当然他们根本不知道，汤姆，那一刻最终会变得多么严肃和多么悲剧。好吧。又是一集精彩的节目，多米尼克。谢谢。我们将在第三集中找出通往战争之路的下一步，届时我们将看看来自俄国和法国的观点，而不是像计划的那样在柏林举行游船派对，那是你最初为这一集计划的，不，我们
could have been having that we could have been having maybe a governess in monmart strong words in the nursery but instead we're going to have french diplomats and we will be introducing some excellent french ambassadors if you like comic French ambassadors, this series is definitely the one for you. So they will be featuring on our next episode. And if you're a member of the Restless History Club, you can of course get that and everything else that follows the whole series right now. And if you're not, you can sign up and get it at therestlesshistory.com. So till next time, goodbye. Auf Wiedersehen. I'm Marina Hyde.
本可以有那个，我们本可以有蒙马特的家庭教师，托儿所里的强硬话语，但相反，我们将有法国外交官，我们将介绍一些优秀的法国大使，如果你喜欢滑稽的法国大使，这个系列绝对适合你。所以他们将出现在我们的下一集中。如果你是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员，你当然可以现在就得到那一集以及随后的整个系列。如果你不是，你可以在 therestlesshistory.com 注册并获取它。所以下次见，再见。Auf Wiedersehen。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets,
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和现场门票的优先购买权，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。